[Music]
[Applause]
Steve Tasker the former bills all pro
and uh former Hall of Fame finalist
joining us on the program Steve what do
you make of uh what Sean McDermott had
to say about this situation
yeah I don't think they know if he's
going to play or not I'm sure Josh feels
like he's going to be able to get there
um I think that what it comes down to
Dan is they're gonna
weigh the risk of How likely it is that
Josh hurts himself further and has to
drag this elbow thing around all season
and How likely it is that he can play
play well and they can win I think
that's the that's the real question I
don't think there's any question he
could drag himself out there and play
but how much of a risk is it to the rest
of the season if he does I don't think
they know that how important is he when
you look at all the quarterbacks and
what's at stake now where Buffalo this
is supposed to be their year his year
uh the the importance can they can they
survive without him and if so how long
yeah I think they can survive without
him but
every in every game they play this year
he's going to be the best player on the
field I think they're almost treading
into places where they where the
Patriots went with Brady and where the
Colts went with Peyton Manning
he is an enormous eraser Dan whatever
goes wrong it don't matter he can
overcome it I mean that's where they're
at with him and that's you know that's
how good he is uh he can I mean you you
take that last play of the game when he
threw it 70 yards last week at the end
of the game you can't imagine how hard
it is for a defense to defend that much
field every play but he forces you to do
it and that's um and he can overcome it
so whatever goes wrong so you can throw
whatever you want at him as a defense uh
it may not matter even if you get it
right that's how good he is so they're
gonna miss him now Case Keenum can play
they can play they can win with Case
Keenum no question but they gotta the
rest of the rosters got to rise up now
they got to play really good and it's
going to look a lot different with Case
Keenum than Josh Allen that's for sure
well I wondered if you had a reliable
running game then maybe you do take a
little bit of pressure off whoever's the
quarterback you don't have that luxury
here uh does the game plan change at all
if Case Keenum is your starter against
the Vikings as opposed to Josh Allen
yeah I don't know you could go with the
exact same game plan that you do with
Josh Allen but it's going to look
different Case Keenum is going to make
different choices than than Josh does
you're going to spread the football
around the running backs are going to
get the ball a little more the tight end
is going to get the ball a little more
Gabe Davis is going to get the ball a
little more uh the the offense really
depends on Josh and Steph Diggs a lot
when it's healthy and you know they
really you know they really don't need
the running game to be all that good
with Josh Allen and Steph Diggs in there
so they really don't depend on it with
Case Keenum it's going to look different
they may hand it off once or twice more
than they do otherwise certainly when
they drop back the pass they're going to
take the check down a lot more than they
did with Josh Allen
um and case keenum's not the runner that
Josh is either so even if you go in
there with the exact same game plan it
will manifest itself completely
differently with Case Keenum taking
Snaps and it does with Josh and I
wondered we're talking to Steve Tasker
the former bills all pro if you start to
look at where we thought the bills were
going to be in that division they would
have a luxury of a few games a cushion
you don't have that cushion the Jets are
better than we thought Miami's going to
be there it feels like and you lost last
week so it's not like you go let's sit
him down for a week or two and see if
rest helps it
yeah I mean they're 0-2 in the division
you know the only two losses they've got
are the Dolphins and the Jets and I'll
say this too the Jets you got to tip
your hat to them
there's a lot of teams in the NFL that
are really good that would have gotten
beat by the Jets last weekend they
played really good uh when you get it
when you get an effort like that out of
the Jets and Zach Wilson doesn't make
mistakes they're pretty tough out the
bills found that out
that's you know so the bills are sitting
there they're a half game maybe a game
and a half up on the Chiefs
um
because of the head-to-head the bills
are sitting there in a nice spot they're
the one seed they've beaten the Chiefs
they've beaten the Ravens and they've
beaten Tennessee the other three
division leaders but right in their own
division they lose this weekend they
could go from the one seed to the third
seed in their own division with a loss
so there's a lot of there's a lot of bad
things that can happen if they don't win
this game even though it's an out of
conference out of division game so
you're right I mean you got to keep
pressing this is a team that went to the
three seed last year
but felt like they were good enough at
the end of the season to be the one and
they just weren't there so if you're
gonna give yourself the best chance to
go to the Super Bowl you got to win
games like this game against Minnesota
at a time when there's like four teams
five teams nipping at your heels in the
standings yeah and you got home field
advantage or you know there's no team
that would rely on home field advantage
probably more than Buffalo would with
the elements there in January you've
lived in Buffalo you played in Buffalo
the importance of this year's team to
that Community considering everything
that's happened in the last you know 30
years 40 years is what
yeah it's they're a wagon man I mean
this team's this team's full it's a
wrecking crew they're really good when
they're clicking on all cylinders
they're a sight to behold in the in this
this town lives on them and they're it's
the nectar of the Gods for these this
fan base I mean it's unbelievable uh
they love this crew it's a it's a love
it's a great group of guys uh who like
each other a lot it's a fan base who who
kind of the the bills Mafia thing is all
about family so it's a fan base with a
lot of affection not only for their team
but for each other because of the
commiseration of two decades of
purgatory that they went through
together so it's a fan base that's
really got a kind of a family feel to it
I mean you've got fans that don't know
each other that are embracing kind of
loving each other it's a cool atmosphere
around this team the expectations were
almost so high it was scary for a lot of
bills fans they never been in that spot
before
um and then they get out of the gate
against the world champions and then the
one seat in the conference with the Rams
and the Tennessee Titans and they thump
those guys they get off to a rousing
start they drop a game to Miami in a
game where they were really injured
and it was that thing in Miami with the
Heat and the humidity that really it's
something I never went through as a
player down there we never had a game
like that in Miami for all the years I
played down there it was never like that
for our team and it came out of nowhere
so this became with expectations and a
fan base
I mean they cannot wait to watch this
team play every week I mean they it's
like they're just looking forward to it
because it's you know it's like I said
it's nectar of the Gods here for this
fan base it's like you know they're a
crack pipe and this and this town is is
an addict they can't get enough of this
team
uh Before I Let You Go I was wondering
about this I know you were a finalist
for the Hall of Fame and you were a
special teamer but I didn't know if did
they create the special teamer for the
Pro Bowl because of you
no just after me I was you know Bill
Bates and mossy tatupu were a big factor
in that a lot of great players back then
I got in in 85 and the Pro Bowl thing
came around 82-83 okay what happened Dan
The rosters got a little bigger in the
NFL
and to maximize your chance to win they
needed everybody to contribute so now
they started having professional special
teams players back in the early 80s they
had guys who did it as a team and they
were got they were here and there was a
guy around you know Hank Bauer from the
Chargers and guys like that around the
league who had made a name for
themselves being able to do it
and guys like him inspired the league to
say you know what we got to get a guy in
there because the rosters were bigger
then and the game expanded and more and
more guys down the roster got a chance
to really help the team on game day so
now during my time you'll have and even
now you'll have a half a dozen eight
guys
that are professional special teams
players so I came up and I kind of
played in The Golden Era of that where
there was no salary cap and they had
guys on the team that were just special
teams players and so yeah I was I was a
semifinal never made a finalists a bunch
like yeah a bunch of times I was a
semi-finalist never got to the final
list but you know that ship has sailed
for me I'm I'm you know I'm out of my
I'm out of my years of eligibility for
the for the voters to vote me in and I'm
I I can't be bitter about being in that
conversation it's flattering I
appreciated the debate when I had a
chance to go on but uh yeah somebody
someday somebody maybe it'll be Matt
Slater uh that gets in go and hope he
does
um but you've got to be the most famous
special teamer in NFL history
non-return now maybe now yeah maybe at
this point in history I will be but
there'll be other guys too I I was on a
great team Dan I got a lot of exposure
because of that I made some really nice
plays during that time that team was
really good
um and that puts you up on the
consciousness of the average fan not
just Bills fans and I've I've always
been really appreciative of what
happened to me and the things I was able
to do on that team they were a great
bunch of guys it was fun and I you know
even though we were we lost four Super
Bowls in a row it was a blast to be on
that team a blast
um I'll never forget it was some it was
a gift and uh and I treat it as such and
I appreciate the conversation but yeah
my I think for me the Hall of Fame that
that ship has sailed even though I
appreciated the time I had been
considered what's the Super Bowl you
replay in your mind occasionally
well I mean they all get replayed it
somewhere they don't you know it's not
that that they don't wake me up at night
but sometimes I can't get to sleep you
know
you know that's more the way it is right
so
um they all get I all have I have
replays of all of them and mostly
because of the great guys that were on
all four of those teams you know and the
guys but if you see like uh Bill
Parcells bad things come into your mind
or you see Troy Aikman bad things come
into your mind
no
I got a lot of respect for those guys
um you don't get to the Super Bowl and
you don't get to play two and 14 teams
that are struggling you get a Play Hall
of Fame well you can respect them but
but when you see them it's like oh that
brings back bad memories
yeah you know what though Dan I think
his players most of the guys think you
know it was it wasn't them it was me you
know it was me I should have played
better
it's great to talk to you uh hopefully
appreciate you man hopefully you're uh
it is day to day with Josh Allen and uh
he's able to I think it is to get
through this get through this yeah I
think it is I think it is day to day
there's a real chance he plays
um and I think it comes down to like I
said it's that risk do the team really
believe that he can go out there and
play four quarters make every throw make
every play and not be any worse for wear
if nothing weird happens
then you got a chance for him but this
is a culture here in Buffalo they're
pretty cautious with guys they like them
to get 100 they like the guy to feel
like he's ready to play 100 so there's
that too yeah so I don't I really think
it's up in the air right now
thank you Steve great to talk to you
all right Dan be good that's Steve
Tasker former bills all pro and uh
former sideline reporter NFL on CBS